[Music]
face on the ground keep it up for
anything
you shared a cell with your old man in
no time I don't know what to do anymore
I keep having this conversation over and
over
nobody asked you to be the parent who's
it gonna be then it's me and you
remember are you going ran around you
know so he's dead what we found on this
morning he's dead
you think Brendan today - are you sure
you don't know where he is I'm sure a
lot of me do you think he could have
done it the police are gonna find em
we're gonna figure this out okay
look you don't get it together he's your
brother
if they find him first they're gonna
bring him up here all he's got were you
working last night just looking to get
some information didn't show your face
after what your brother did he's missing
Helen is
they'll let us find any messing around
again the next time you need to see
something for yourself
what are you doing you're not a cop
there may be someone else there last
night they have known I was up there I
don't want to see you get into something
you can't back away from
finder we're in what are you doing this
is my brother tell me where he was
supposed to die all right
you think Brandon is a murderer how I
got
[Music]
you
you